من مركز جباليا طبي ينضم الينا المدير
العام لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه في غزه
الدكتور منير البرش دكتور منير اهلا بك
بالنسبه لهذه المناطق القريبه من مركز
جباليا الطبي والتي تستهدف بالقصف
الاسرائيلي بشكل يومي كيف يتم التعامل مع
الحالات التي تستقدم منها من اصابات وجثث
للشهداء
ايضا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ال القطف
اي خلال الثلاث ايام السابقه كان هو
الاعنف
والاشد منذ بدايه الحرب والاحزمه الناريه
يعني تجعل من هذا المركز الصغير يهتز كانه
قطعه قماش في كل لحظه فهذه الاحزمه
الناريه التي استهدفت المباني المجاوره ل
مركز جبالي الطبي وايضا المناطق الشرقيه
اي حتى اللحظه منذ الصباح ونحن في الصباح
وصلنا ما يقارب ال 20 شهيد و25 جريح
والعشرات ما زالوا تحت الانقاض الغبار في
كل مكان البيوت مهدمه الاحياء مهدمه ونحن
يعني نعمل هذه
المقابله قبل قليل مع مراسلكم الاستاذ انس
كان قصف عنيف صوره
بجوارنا في حي سكني لال علوان لم يصل منه
شهيد لكن هذا الحي الذي اعرفه هو
اي مليء بالسكان والنازحين وهيكون من تحت
الانقاد العشرات منذ الصباح ونحن
نستقبل الاطفال اطفال صغار السن شهداء
ونحضن وهم ياتوننا لا نستطيع حسبهم الله
ونعم الوكيل لذلك الاحتلال يستهدف الم
بعنف شديد يستهدف شمال غزه جبال يا مخيم
جبال يا بيت لاه يا بيت حنون يستهدف
التفاح والدرج يستهدف مدينه غزه يرسل
برسائل
اي لعائلات باكملها اننا
س نقصف دواوينهم عائله غزال وعائله خيال
وعائله كبيره في التفاح ارسل لهم هذه
الرسائل منذ الصباح
وطالبهم بالنزوح هذا القصف العنيف يريد
يراد به تصفيه الوجود الصحي في كل مناطق
شمال قطاع غزه يهدف الى تشريد اكثر من 800
ال مسمه وحرمان الاف الجرحى والاطفال
والمرضى المزمنين من الخدمات
الصحيه ما زالت هذه المجازر متتاليه ام
طالت كل مناطق قطاع غزه طبعا كان قبل يوم
استهداف لمستشفى
العوده وطبعا
اعتقال مديره العام الدكتور احمد مهنا
وعشره من الكوادر الطبيه ايضا من بينهم
الدكتور عدنان البرش رئيس
قسم العظام في مستشفى الشفاء الذي اكمل
عمله في مستشفى العوده ايضا الاحتلال وصل
اعتقالي لاكثر من 100 100 معتقل من
كوادرنا الصحيه على رائسهم الدكتور محمد
ابو سلميه مدير عام الشفاء واحمد الكحلوت
مدير عام كمال عدوان واحمد مهنا مدير عام
مستشفى العوده ايضا استشهد اكثر من 310 من
كوادرنا الطبيه واكثر من 100 سياره اسعاف
لكن اي ما زالت الوتيره لمغادره المصابين
هي نفس الوتيره عن طريق المعبر 400
133 مصاب هم الذين خرجوا من
22000 جريح وهذا الامر الحقيقه معيب ومخجل
ومخزي لامتنا العربيه وجارتنا مصر التي لا
تسمح بخروج الجرحى حتى اللحظه الا بهذا
العدد النظر اليسير 12 جريح في اليوم فقط
هذا الامر مخجل الحقيقه امام هذه الاعداد
الكبيره من الجرحى الان بعد تصفيه الجرحى
لدينا 5000 يصنف في حاله الخطر الشديد
والذي يتوجب اخراجهم في كل لحظه من اجل
عمليات جراحيه سريعا للاسف مع كل هذا
العدد الكبير من الجرحى ومن كل هذه
المسميات لا يخرج الا 12 جريح فقط او 16
جريح يوميا ن دكتور البرش الان في ظل هذه
المعطيات التي ذكرتها ما الذي بقي متاحا
في شمال قطاع غزه على مستوى المراكز
الطبيه وفرق الاغاثه للتدخل على مستوى
المواقع
المستهدفه الشيء المتاح هو الموت فقط لان
الناس تستنزف في الشوارع وتموت في الشوارع
كما هو الحاصل الان بعدما دمرت مستشفيات
الاندونيسي ومستشفيات كمال العدوان ماذا
بقي ومستشفى العوده النساء يعني في الصباح
اتت امراه وتحمل جنينها قد نزل راسه لا
تجد من يول
ودناها على باب المركز الطبي الحقيقه لا
يوجد الا الموت الان في كل شارع وفي كل
زاويه وفي كل حاره الموت هو سيد الموقف
هذه الاباده هي عباده جماعيه هذا القصف
العنيف يراد به يعني اباده الشعب
الفلسطيني يراد به تصفيه المنظومه الصحيه
يراد به قتل الاطفال من الصباح ونحن
نستقبل اطفال بين
ايدينا قلوبنا تجمدت وعقولنا جمدت ونحن
نمسك بهؤلاء الاطفال
كالرياح هذه اعدامات اعدامات واباده
جماعيه الي عنان في في في في مدينه غزه
يستغيثون منذ الليله والنار يعني تلتهب
وتحرق ابنائهم ماتوا حرقا في في في الليله
الماضيه اتى عش من ال النجار
محروقين الحروق تتجاوز 60% وال 70% يعني
الموت هو طريقهم
الموت اجمل لهم كثير من المصابين الان
وتعج هذه القاعه الصغيره في مركز جبال
الطبي بالجرحى يفضلون الموت لانه لا علاج
لا دواء لا مسكن عملنا اربع عمليات جراحيه
الليله والله والله لا يوجد دواء مخدر لهم
والطبيب يقول اما ان يموت او احاول يا
دكتور قلته حاول مات اثنين وعا اثنين
الحقيقه نحن بدون مخدر وقد صورت هذه
العمليه الجراحيه بدون مخدر والالم يصرخ
يصرخ الطبيب لك المريض لكن ماذا نفعل امان
خيار اما نتركه يموت وقد خرجت احشاؤه
كلها ووقف الطبيب يلملم ويلملم وجاءت
امراه بعده خرج الرحم وخرج ماذا اقول
والله والله اشياء اشياء لا يستطيع
الانسان ان يتكل التفاصيل التي ترويها لنا
تفاصيل مريعه وصعبه دكتور منير البرش
لمجرد تخيلها فقط فما بالك انتم تشاهدونها
يوميا وعلى مدار الساعه ونشاهد الان قصفا
جديدا يستهدف غزه خلال هذه اللحظات يبدو
انه قصف قوي جدا بالنظر الى كميه الدخان
المنبعث من هذا الموقع الصوره ملتقطه من
غلاف غزه لهذا الموقع الجديد داخل القطاع
الذي يستهدفه جيش الاحتلال في هذه الساعات
الاولى من هذا الصباح شكرا لضيفنا من مركز
جباليه الطبيه المدير العام لوزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه في غزه الدكتور منير البرش وفي
الاثناء ننوه الى الخبر العاجل الذي
نشاهده على شاشتنا نق
عن المدير العام او الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
يشير
الان بالقول ما زلنا نخوض معارك ومواجهات
مباشره في قطاع غزه